>>> GOOD AFTERNOON AND WELCOME
TO "THE ARENA" WHERE ON THIS DAY
WE HONOR THE MEMORY OF THE DRUM
MAJOR.
I'M ERNIE JOHNSON, GRATEFUL TO
BE HERE, TO HOST AN HOUR-LONG
ROUNDTABLE DISCUSSION WHICH WILL
BEGIN IN JUST A FEW MINUTES.
FROM THE PULPIT OF EBENEZER
BAPTIST CHURCH HERE IN ATLANTA
SHORTLY BEFORE HIS DEATH, DR.
MARTIN LUTHER KING JR. TOLD THE
CONGREGATION THAT HE WANTED TO
BE REMEMBERED AS A SERVANT AND
AS A DRUM MAJOR FOR JUSTICE,
PEACE AND RIGHTEOUSNESS.
WE WILL REFLECT ON HIS LEGACY.
WE BEGIN WITH A VISIT TO
MEMPHIS.
FOR YEARS ON THIS DAY ON OUR
SHOW WE'VE SPOKEN OF THE
NATIONAL CIVIL RIGHTS MUSEUM AND
ALWAYS FOUND MYSELF SAYING, YOU
KNOW, I NEED TO GET THERE AND
SEE IT FOR MYSELF.
WELL, LAST WEEK I DID.
MY WIFE CHERYL AND I FOUND
OURSELVES WADING INTO A SEA OF
HISTORY, TAKING PHOTOGRAPHS.
IMMERSED IN THE STORIES OF
HEROES UPON HEROES.
THERE ARE, INSIDE THE WALLS OF
THE CIVIL RIGHTS MUSEUM IN
MEMPHIS, CHAPTERS OF THE CIVIL
RIGHTS STRUGGLE PAINFUL TO THE
CORE.
AT THE SAME TIME, FIGURES IN
BRONZE STAND AS WITNESS TO
COURAGE AND RESOLVE, FACES OF
DETERMINATION MOLDED AND CAST,
HARKENING BACK TO A TIME WHEN
THEY WERE MOVED TO ACTION, AND
NOW THEY STAND IMMOVABLE,
SERVING AS TESTAMENT TO THE
SOLIDARITY AND SACRIFICE IT TOOK
TO ENACT CHANGE FAR TOO LONG IN
COMING.
INSIDE THESE WALLS THERE ARE
STORIES, SO MANY STORIES.
I WAS INTRODUCED TO CLARA
LOOPER, THE CLOEMG HIGH SCHOOL
TEACHER WHO ORGANIZED LUNCH
COUNTER SIT-INS, WHO WAS
ARRESTED TWO DOZEN TIMES WHO WAS
DENIED THE RIGHT TO SIT AT A
RESTAURANT OF HIS CHOOSING AND
SAID TONIGHT IS THE NIGHT,
HISTORY COMPELS US TO GO.
LET HISTORY ALONE BE OUR FINAL
JUDGE.
EARNEST GREEN, ONE OF THE LITTLE
ROCK NINE WHO ENROLLED AT
ALL-WHITE CENTRAL HIGH AND WAS
THE FIRST TO GRADUATE, DESPITE A
WRITTEN PLEA FROM A WHITE
WORRIED SENIOR THAT HE NOT
ATTEND THE CEREMONY.
YOU DESERVE YOUR SHEEP SKIN AS
MUCH AS ANYBODY ELSE AND I WOULD
NOT STOP YOU FORGETTING IT.
HOWEVER, THERE ARE MANY, AS YOU
KNOW, WHO WOULD GLADLY DO SO.
IT WOULD BE A TIME THAT I AND
HUNDREDS OF OTHERS WISH TO NOT
HAVE MARRED.
THERE WAS JOANNE ROBINSON, AN
ENGLISH PROFESSOR WHO ON THE DAY
ROSA PARKS WAS ARRESTED FOR NOT
SURRENDERING HER SEAT ON THE BUS
WENT TO AN OFFICE ON THE COLLEGE
AND SECRETLY MIMEOGRAPHED
THOUSANDS OF FLYERS CALLING FOR
A ONE-DAY BUS BOYCOTT AND
DISTRIBUTED THEM THROUGH OUT THE
CITY.
.
YOU READ WORDS FROM THE BROTHER
OF MEDGAR EVERS, AS CHARLES
EVERS BECAME THE FIRST AFRICAN
AMERICAN MAYOR OF A SOUTHERN
CITY SINCE THE DAYS OF
RECONSTRUCTION.
ULTIMATELY YOUR JOURNEY IN
MEMPHIS SO POWERFUL TAKES YOU TO
ROOM 306 AT THE LORRAINE MOTEL,
AND WHILE YOU KNOW THE STORY OF
APRIL 4th, 1968, THERE IS THIS
FEELING.
I WISH I COULD ARTICULATE IT.
I CAN'T, OF SEEING THAT ROOM AND
THAT BALCONY AND THAT BOARDING
HOUSE ACROSS THE STREET WHERE IT
IS BELIEVED THE SHOT WAS FIRED
THAT TOOK THE LIFE OF DR. MARTIN
LUTHER KING JR., AND THERE IS
THIS, JUST MOMENTS BEFORE THE
DEADLY SHOT RANG OUT, DR. KING,
STANDING ON THE BALCONY, HAD
BEEN IN CONVERSATION WITH
SAXOPHONIST BRANCH ON STREET
LEVEL, ASKING HIM TO PLAY HIS
FAVORITE "PRECIOUS LORD TAKE MY
HAND" IN AN UPCOMING RALLY AND,
QUOTE, PLAY IT REAL PRETTY.
BRANCH'S RESPONSE WE ARE TOLD
WAS, YOU KNOW I WILL, DOC.
THERE WAS SO MUCH TO TAKE IN, SO
MUCH TO PROCESS IN THIS VISIT,
IT'S OVERWHELMING.
THEN AS YOU MAKE YOUR WAY TOWARD
THE EXIT, YOU SEE THE WORK OF
SCULPTOR MICHAEL PAVLOV SKI, THE
MOVEMENT TO OVERCOME.
IT STANDS IN THE MUSEUM'S ATRIUM
AND ENCAPSULATES WHAT YOU'